con mucha emoción se vivió el
lanzamiento de la cápsula dragón que se
dirige en estos momentos hasta la
estación espacial internacional aquí en
este centro espacial en tu luz pues la
gente aplaudió mucho sobre todo en el
momento en que el cohete falcon 8 puso
en órbita a cruz dragón es decir a unos
200 kilómetros de distancia de la tierra
por ahora se va a tomar realmente un día
la cápsula en llegar hasta la estación
espacial y durante ese tiempo va a darle
la vuelta a la tierra unas 16 veces para
ganar velocidad será también el momento
para que los cuatro astronautas a bordo
del protagonista sari que sus cuerpos
vayan adaptándose también a la
microgravedad antes de comenzar esta
misión de seis meses que será bastante
arduo con 12 horas de trabajo diario
entre ejercicio físico y también
experimentos científicos uno de los
puntos claves precisamente será este
sábado porque será el acoplamiento de
cruz dragón a la estación espacial
internacional gracias a los adaptadores
de acoplamiento presurizado sabrá que
también verificar que la hermeticidad
funciona antes de que
diferentes a tripulaciones pues puedan
encontrarse y darse ese abrazo de
bienvenida el acoplamiento esto está
previsto para las 5 10 de la mañana de
este sábado hora del este de eeuu